I'm a trump supporter and I stand with
President Donald J Trump and the
that's happening to him right now is
disgraceful but uh I'm a comedian and I
started making videos on social media
back in 2016. I blew up on Facebook and
this was before uh Trump was even the
nominee I blew up on Facebook I was uh
talking about I was addressing some of
some of my friends who were talking
about we should move back to Africa and
I said oh hell no oh oh oh hell to the
no I ain't never been there and I don't
plan on going there so I told them hell
no I'm not moving to Africa I love
America I said y'all take y'all black
asses over there I'm staying right here
in America with these white folks I'm
sorry I'm sorry I love my freedom over
here and that video is super viral and I
was eating fried chicken in the video
it was it wasn't set up because it was I
was I was on my lunch break it was a lot
of videos my first video and I was
finishing my lunch before I went back to
work and I had some fried chicken